[Music]
all right so we're going to get started
and i guess i will start by saying good
evening to everyone
i i'm on mountain time so is john
john our speaker so it's only 6 30 for
us
we will try not to keep you too late
i am dr larry gray i i'm co-organizer of
pi data salt lake city
and for those of you that don't know pi
data is a group of meetups regional
conferences and one big global
conferences that's going to be coming up
here really soon and it's all supported
by num focus
and num focus is this organization that
physically supports some of the most
awesome open source software
uh
that's out there for patent as we talked
about pandas last week they support the
pandas matplotlib all these uh julia
language they support them also
um and so they allow us to get together
and do all these meetups under their
name
but today we're here
to discuss wildfires right
wildfires in the u.s have burned almost
3 million acres so far this year
and that's more than the size of
delaware and rhode island combined
so it is with special excitement and
that i'm pleased to welcome dr john
calder to our monthly gathering um john
is one of the world's experts i think i
read a lot of his papers so i i feel
this way now on paleo ecology fire
ecology and microbial ecology he earned
his phd in ecology from the university
of wyoming in 2016.
uh he has published um extensively um
with citations with over 300 citations
of his work he's been published in some
of the top journals in the world
uh
i know this because i submit it to pnas
proceedings the national academy of
sciences my paper was rejected he had a
paper accepted so
he's the better scientist it seems uh
his work uh has been showcased both on
wyoming public radio and national public
radio on npr
so if you ever wonder why these fires
are getting bigger uh john is gonna
hopefully demystify how climate change
may increase both the frequency of
wildfires and amount of area burned
and he will show how the past climate
changes and their effects on wildfires
can provide constraints on potential
future wildfire risk
uh i think well what he will do he will
quantify for us how much different
recent wildfires are from those that
occurred a thousand years thousands of
years ago
um i believe john was made for this type
of research uh it means getting out into
the field getting your hands dirty so it
it should come as no surprise that he
loves back country skiing trail running
mountain biking and all those sorts of
event uh
activities so please join me in
welcoming dr john calder
all right that's that's your signal i
would shake your hand normally if we're
on stage but
there you go
take it away john
well thanks thanks larry for that really
nice introduction um that was very nice
of you
i um
i like larry said i did my phd um
graduating 2016. i am now a data
scientist at mx
here in lehi utah it's been an awesome
transition i've really enjoyed it i my
wife was worried about the intellectual
stimulation she thought i might get a
little bit bored
the problems we're working on are super
fun they're really hard and everybody i
work with is just as smart as everybody
i've always known and so i've really
enjoyed this transition to data science
um
and yeah i
couldn't be happier especially being
back in the wasatch actually grew up
here so being back in the wasatch is
super fun so i can start talking let me
share my screen
i always feel like a luddite because
it's always hard to do
um here we go
oh man
you know what i realize this is how much
of a luddite i am i'll zoom to i don't
know how to change
um
keynote to fill the whole screen
enter full screen that's probably not
going to do it you know what
you guys will just be uh
is anybody else out there can help me
what do you bet this does it
wow
and are you seeing the timer or are you
seeing uh we're saying your uh
presentation slides
yeah yeah no worries this this is a part
of the game
then when i was making the joke about
feeling like a luddite yeah it turns out
i was it was true i'm i am a luddite
okay there are my notes
see that it's gonna work
i believe
how about now
oh there we go full screen looking good
okay sweet thanks sorry all right
so
we're going to talk about understanding
paleo wildfires with data science you
can think of it
that's kind of a
i use the word data science in the title
mostly because it's a mix of
statistics and algorithmic thinking
whereas if i wanted to quickly summarize
data science i might do something
vague like that so
we'll we'll talk about wildfires for the
last couple thousand years using a mix
of tools that i cobbled together to try
to understand some of the past
now
when we're talking about fire just this
is just kind of a prelude for the entire
talk we're talking about fire
whenever you think about fire and the
causes of fire
you have to be really specific with the
type of vegetation
right and it might not seem immediately
clear but if you just think about it for
just a little bit it becomes pretty
obvious but i remember even when i
started this i had i didn't think hard
enough about how different vegetation
how vegetation burns differently so i'm
going to be talking about forests like
this we call these sub-alpine forests
these are high elevation mountain
forests you can think of them if we're
in utah here
think the uintas think um
camas and above those nice forests where
you go in it's mostly
lodgepole some furs and spruce the trees
are really close together if you stand
in the middle of the forest you can't
see
you know the sky above you is filled
with
branches overhanging so these
and that's important because this the
structure of the vegetation determines
how these fires burn and these fires are
going to burn a lot differently than say
like um
fires as you're driving to saint george
and you're driving through the pinyon
juniper forest you know we've had some
huge fires in utah along there um kind
of in the middle of utah one of the
largest fires in the state's history i
think it is the largest burned down
there um
or if you think about like southern
california the chaparral community the
huge fires we have
down there each of these fires because
the vegetation is different
it's
the chemical composition of the
vegetation is different and then the way
the fuels come together is different
each of those factors caused that those
fires to burn differently and the
controls on those fires to be different
so with that prelude think
forests where i go camping up in the
uintas and that vegetation type is what
we're going to be talking about today
and we have to be really specific with
that vegetation type so
um
with that long ramble prelude let's talk
let's do a little history
um thinking about fires and forest fires
and fighting them this is gifford
pinchot he was the
leader of what became the first leader
of what eventually became the national
forest service
and he
had this great argument where he's
trying to
argue before congress about why we need
to manage the forest as a resource um
he argued that this was a resource that
we can use for profit for value and we
can manage that to take care of it and
use it as such and he had this great
quote in 1910 where he said
kind of um really confidently
today we understand that fires are
wholly within the control of men
um
[Music]
pretty strong statement right like man
is powerful look at what we can do
this is 1910 later that year
he ate a bit of crow he in 1910 later
that year
an area the size of connecticut burned
across northern idaho and montana
so this was a monster fire it um
just like today
like we're having today the army came to
help fight the buffalo soldiers that um
had fought previous wars the first black
regiment they came to help fight the
fires it was they did everything they
could used all the tools and resources
they had and there was nothing they
could do to stop they consumed towns it
was just a monster um ken burns has done
a documentary on it in the last few
years um and then there was a book that
was super good called the big burn um if
you want to read about that
it gives a good overview of uh the
history of the national forest service
so this happened in 1910 and it happened
right after they thought we've got this
fire thing under control we can beat
these we are we are strong
and it was 88 or 78 years
decades generations before
the us ever experienced another fire
like that that we could not put out for
decades after that we started fighting
fires especially after world war ii we
had all the machines to from the war to
repurpose
the bombers
etc to repurpose to help us fight fires
and all the fires we fought in those
decades
were easily managed they were put out
and we started to gain the hubris again
that fire is wholly within the control
of man
and it wasn't until 1988 that we had a
fire that we could not stop you can see
these flames are extending hundreds of
feet above the canopy
when when we're talking about these
forests these sub-alpine forests the
high uintas
fires don't burn across the ground they
burn from tree top to tree top when the
trees catch fire they don't start
burning they explode
because the water inside of the tissue
in the trees is expanding the um
the chemical compounds that you smell
that nice piney smell those are volatile
organic compounds the first thing to
burn and when the tree goes they you can
you can watch a fire from a distance and
you can see little flares burst because
these trees are exploding
and
you cannot fight a fire
when it's burning from tree top to tree
top there's nothing that we can do
when you have 70 mile an hour winds and
we've had a bad drought
we tried you know in just like in 1910
the army came in this is the national
guard they built the largest fire line
ever constructed in history where a fire
line um conventional firefighting in
these types of forests is
mowing down an area a break in the fuels
and the continuity of the fuels and
hoping that that will then stop the fire
the problem is that embers can launch
for
hundreds of meters some over a kilometer
sometimes you know chunks of wood
logs launching when these trees explode
well past the fire line in 1988 if
you've been to yellowstone um the grand
canyon of the yellowstone super
impressive um
canyon and the fire the yellowstone fire
back then in 88 the fire jumped across
the grand canyon of the yellowstone
and
so you know there are times while we can
fight some fires in these forests when
conditions are extreme
um
there's nothing we can do when you have
high winds um severe drought
uh we we cannot fight them
and just like in 1910 and 1988 the
yellowstone fire didn't stop burning
until snow fell and so you can see i'm
kind of excited about these in a weird
way i wanted to understand these fires i
was a young kid when yellowstone burned
i was only six years old but i remember
vivintly vividly excuse me vividly the
news i can remember the news stories
about the
smoke coming across the country i
remember seeing
interviews from people talking about the
causes of that fire and i wanted to
understand those fires i wanted to
understand
why do they happen how often do they
happen
and then i wanted to understand
something of the ecological consequences
which i also study but we won't get into
today um
because we hadn't seen anything like
that it was new it seemed maybe it seems
a little bit silly now because we've had
multiple huge gnarly fires that we
cannot stop
but in 1988 this was really unique it
was portrayed as this assault on our
national jewel that was one headline
that i saw so anyway
so i wanted to understand these and so
my wife and i we moved to wyoming to
she followed me to do a phd and she got
to go to grad school there too and our
one of our first weekends there this is
a pretty sweet photo which is here on
the left we wanted to drive to one of
the state parks and we took some back
roads through the forest and we got
stopped because a beaver had built a dam
across the road that was pretty cool i
like the outdoors utah is an outdoor
state sort of no wyoming's the outdoor
state
there's so much land there's so much
opportunity it's great i never had a
beaver build a dam across the dirt road
in utah so i loved it there
we were in laramie wyoming the south
eastern corner there
and i had a lot of help these are some
undergrads that helped me
lug in gear because we worked in um
a wilderness area where we had to lug in
all the gear
and so i wanted to understand these
fires
and one way that we can do that when we
can we can understand today and
understand what's happening today is to
look into the past
and see
what caused these large fires before how
often did they happen in the past and
we're fortunate that lakes in mountain
systems um can preserve
evidence of past fires you can see the
smoke here burning you can't see my
cursor you can see the smoke here
burning and down in the bottom left-hand
corner
there's a small lake it's only that
one's only a few feet deep this is just
outside of my study area but as the fire
burns nearby the lake
charcoal is going to fall onto that lake
and get buried into the lake sediment
and preserve evidence of the past
wildfires because every year a little
bit of sediment accumulates on the lake
so anything that was there gets buried
and entrained over time and we can then
go and take a core
and go back thousands of years in the
inner mountain in the rocky mountains we
can go back to the end of the last ice
age
as soon as the uh landscape clears of
ice sediment starts accumulating so we
can go back between depending on the
lake between 12 and 16 000 years
super fun super cool to be able to go
back in time like that with these
records
and
so a lot of people before me have tried
to understand this process they've tried
to understand
they would go and dig up cores and they
would see charcoal in there and they
wanted to know like well when does some
charcoal mean that there's a fire nearby
a lake
and they did a lot of studies i mean
decades of work before i went there and
dozens of grad students and
research labs where they looked at you
know the
how close does a fire need to be before
we detect it in the lake sediment and
they would see evidence of regional
charcoal extra local charcoal and local
charcoal all kind of mixed in there
so that when you go and take a core so
you go into this sediment take a core
and count charcoal back in time
you might see something that look you
wouldn't see something looks like this
this is real
this is a charcoal record for one of my
lakes for the last
2 000 years zero
here on the act on the x-axis is 1950
that's not a mistake
it's 1950 because of radiometric dating
that we were
detonating so many hydrogen bombs that
if you want to
have a good benchmark for any
radiometric dating there is so much
radioactive material in 1950 you can
date back to the week
especially because we were ramping up
the hydrogen bomb explosion so quickly
so
it's a weird zero and so you have to
think of in terms of
i could change the scale but convention
and it's easy to think about zero 1950
and we work into the past
and then this is the number of pieces of
charcoal per centimeter square per year
and so you get some crazy counts that go
up and down and it's kind of noisy and
there may be some peaks that seem really
distinguishable from the background
and a lot of people before me did work
to try to figure out when are these
peaks represent fires and when are they
random processes that we can't
understand
and so
what they found and i'll go through a
few of the methods is that peaks of
charcoal some of these peaks that i've
identified with these hatch marks here
that i'll go into the details in a
second
peaks of charcoal come when there's a
fire within one to three kilometers of a
lake so about a mile radius
so it's it's a cool record that's kind
of like taking a spot on the ground a
big spot a mile radius circle and saying
was there a fire within somewhere within
this radius
within the past
and the way that we do that and the way
that they've done this and they've
validated this with like known fires
with crazy charcoal records where you
can count back in time um the
varved sediment that looks like tree
rings we can think of
um this charcoal here coming from
multiple processes when we count it we
just get the counts
but there are multiple processes giving
rise to these counts and anytime i don't
know if you're not familiar with mixture
models these are super cool tools where
you can
you have your data and you know that
multiple processes gave rise to your
data but you don't have any labels it's
like uh and so you don't know which
process gave rise to a given count
versus another so it's kind of like a a
simple example would be let's say you
you were trying to understand the
difference in height between men and
women measured a bunch of men and
women's height and you forgot to label
male and female and so you know you had
two populations but you couldn't but you
didn't have the labels on the data and
then after that you want to establish
with some probability um that men that
one person came from the male
distribution one person came from the
female
and so that's what we can do with these
charcoal cats we know that
locally there is a process giving rise
to these peaks and that extra locally
there's this process giving rise to some
charcoal coming in that creates some
noise or what may look like noise just
variation in time not the strict
definition of noise in a time series
sense but just kind of like
kind of gnarly stuff going up and down
that we don't really know what it is
and so we can model um the charcoal
counts
with a mixture model to evaluate what's
the probability that given count comes
from this noise distribution which will
use for lack of a better term actually
or this peak component
and we can then set some probability and
say well
if and and you can use be as
conservative or as liberal or liberal as
you want and we were as conservative as
possible so we said well if there's ever
a ch whenever there's a chance uh
where a count of charcoal a peak of
charcoal exceeds the 99th percentile of
the
other distribution the noise
extra local distribution will identify
that as a fire we'll say that that we
have a high probability of that coming
from this process giving rise to these
peaks and wildfires
and we can also screen that given that
these are counts we can screen that with
a poisson process and say you know in
the last 100 years what's the
probability of this variation in
counts coming from just a stochastic
poisson process too so we can do
multiple steps to screen these peaks to
then say confidently that these peaks
are something that are
rising above the noise and they have a
high probability of coming from this
process
when a wildfire burns nearby a lake
and so to understand these large
wildfires i studied a large area so this
is my study here in northern colorado
we were over here in wyoming just across
the border
and just for a little bit of reference
you can see denver down in the corner
and if you've ever been to steamboat
springs this is the mountain range just
uh bordering steamboat springs the ski
resort there
it's about a hundred hundred thousand
hectares um and these are all the lakes
on the top right panel that we court
accord 12 lakes across this wilderness
area
and got fire records for all of those
down here is
me hiking up there on the bottom right
is my
advisor who
was the was part of the muscle of this
operation
and so one way we can think about trying
to understand past wildfire and trying
to understand these large wildfires
is we can get those peaks
but when we're thinking about large
wildfires those only represent some fire
on some point on the landscape you want
to think about
landscape scale wildfires this is what
we call this this
spatial scale we could say we could ask
this question what's the probability
that multiple sites burned at the same
time so given that i detect some fire at
hinman lake over here or oh yeah you
can't see my cursor sorry given that i
detect some fire at one of these lakes
what's the probability that another lake
nearby burned at the same time
and that's what we tried to answer as we
as i went through my dissertation as i
went through my phd and so one of the
biggest challenges in paleo ecology is
age uncertainty so we can take a core
here's which i have photographed on the
right
and these little red dots on this core
are different spots where i took
material for radiometric dating
and over here on the left we'll see is
the plots of these radiometric dates
this the black the small black um
gnarly asymmetric distributions to put
it lightly are the age probability
distributions for a given radiometric
date they can be gnarly like that one on
the top where it's just miserable or
they can be really tight and peaked like
that second one where it's really
high confidence in the age uncertainty
of that piece of sediment
and so we can take points along the core
and date them
and get some estimate of the age
uncertainty but
what we want is you know i might not
detect a fire where i've got where i
have a radial carbon date i might detect
a fire and i will in between these radio
carbon dates so i have depth on the
y-axis here so maybe i detect a fire at
around um
what did i say 60 centimeters down
you know what do we do
when you have detective fire
60 centimeters down what we can do is
and what we did in my dissertation was
kind of the foundation of this work and
what made this happen was that we
modeled the way sediment can accumulate
between these radiocarbon dates used in
using a bayesian-based model of
sedimentation
that assumes that we cannot go backwards
in time um you can't have sediment be
removed from the lake but sediment can
accumulate in any one of the thousands
of possible ways through time so that in
between these dates
randomly sample one of the dates from
these distributions and then allow
a walk between the dates allowing
sediment to accumulate really fast and
then really slow or any combination of
those following just a few principles
that we know about
lake sediment accumulation a priori
before that to constrain that and so
what you get is you get thousands of
ways you know it's just it's just
electrons at this point we just run it
for thousands and thousands of times so
we get thousands of different ways
sediment could have accumulated between
those dates
so that then when we detect a fire at
say 60 centimeters down we can take a
slice from that fire we can take us not
a slice from that fire a slice from that
the way sediment accumulated and get an
age probability distribution for that
fire
given what we know about how sediment
can accumulate given our uncertainty of
our
radiometric dating we can then get some
age estimate
for these past fires and this is a real
one right like i didn't make up these
data it didn't need to this is a real
fire and a real date
and you can see it's the uncertainty is
okay it peaks at about 700 years or so
but there's a wide range of uncertainty
it's
can be between 500 and 900 years old or
if you go way far out there in the thin
tails it's up to a thousand so there's a
lot of uncertainty and we wanted to
capture as all the as much uncertainty
as we could in our modeling because we
wanted to be as conservative as we could
as we're trying to understand these past
wildfires
but the powerful thing that we have when
you do what i love with
bayesian methods
even though they have been complicated
the way the math works out we don't have
um
functions we're left with samples from
these states this is a nice
smooth histogram of these dates when you
have samples from the posterior
distribution like the world is your
oyster you can do whatever you want with
these samples now and so what we did so
here are the
12 lakes this is just a big mess please
don't look at it for too long your
eyeballs will hurt
these are the 12 lakes and each one of
these hatch marks represent fires in the
past i will skip over this now just to
say that we did a lot of work a lot of
charcoal counted a lot of a lot of
electrons wasted on computers
to estimate these peaks and past
wildfires but then what we have is these
age probability distributions for all
the fires that we detected from the
charcoal
so each one of these gray curves
represents the age probability
distribution from a past fire each one
of the
so these are if you count up the
different um
pieces of this figure there are 12 of
them representing those 12 lakes so
there are and these are all the fires
from all those 12 lakes going back for
2000 years
and then the age probability densities
for those given fires and once we have
samples from the posterior then we can
just ask we can do whatever we want
we're really flexible and so we just
used used up more electrons and said
what's the
probability
given all of this uncertainty what's the
probability that one of these peaks
burned within the same century
so we're
we're looking at a broad temporal window
we're saying
how many of these fires burned within
the same 100 year window and we can just
randomly sample from these fires and say
did they burn within that same window
then randomly sample again and do that
thousands and thousands of times so that
you can then say you know how many times
what's the probability
of multiple lakes burning at the same
time which is what i'll show you here on
this next figure
so this next figure here
that's a lot to go over um if anybody
wants to stop me with any questions in
the middle please do we're we're rolling
fast and there's a lot to go over a lot
to wash over you but um
every couple of minutes we need a little
bit of a break
okay
so so going back to this one right we're
trying to calculate the probability that
multiple sites burned across this
landscape and that's what this bottom
panel figure is here
again on the x-axis we have
age in years before 1950
and then the y-axis is the percentage of
side spur where this red line here is
the median probability for the
percentage of sites burns and then this
gray band represents the 95 credible
integrals
and what we see is that
you know
in between this record
on average about 40 of the sites burned
in any 100 year window so you can think
about that like um
yeah just how much how long did it take
the landscape to burn well in any
hundred years
we would have about 40 or so of the
sites burned so it would take a little
over 200 years for all the sites to burn
but what we found was we're thinking
about these large wildfires the key
finding was this peak here in the middle
about 1100 years ago or a thousand years
ago or i say a thousand it's a little
bit easier just about a thousand years
ago
83 of our sampled area burn this nice
peak here
and we can look at you know we have
temperature reconstructions from the
past um there's multiple temp
temperature reconstructions we looked at
one that was based off of proxies that
was focused primarily in the western u.s
for the last 1800 years
this is a temperature reconstruction
from a colleague of mine valerie truay
super cool record
using a whole bunch of different proxies
in the western u.s
that she could do for the last 1500
years
and what i've highlighted here in the
middle is this period called the
medieval climate anomaly
this is a period where about about a
thousand years ago temperatures rose
half a degree c this is when the norse
settled greenland when they could move
out uh from iceland in those areas and
move to what are pretty cold places and
they could settle
they ostensibly even made it to labrador
um it was it was just a little bit
warmer that they could if you read jared
diamond's book right um
what's it called
not guns germs and steel the other one
um
collapse he talks about how they when
they settled on greenland this brief
little warm period you know they had
cows
grass everything was good
it was only about half a degree c um
and what we see is that when we look
back in time that's the time when we see
the only period of time when we see any
evidence of these large wildfires that
we're seeing today
the only time we see them is when we had
a small increase in temperature of just
half a degree c and now we're seeing
these all the time
and
when we go back in time we never see
them or we rarely see them and the only
time that we ever saw them in the past
was when we had a small amount of
warming
of half a degree c
now
that that was that that this is one
chapter in my dissertation um
in 2020
there were three large wildfires near my
original study area
i don't know if you guys have heard
about these
there was the east troublesome fire that
started in october down here kind of in
the middle
there was the cameron peak fire that
started over near fort collins while it
was a little bit west of fort collins
became eventually the biggest fire in
colorado state's history and then there
was this one north on the
colorado wyoming border that was equally
huge
in 2020 there were these three large
wildfires near my original study area
and this prompted other researchers to
you my colleagues to use the same
methods that i developed in my phd and
apply them to a greater area so
the 12 sites that i looked at were these
dots here
i wish you could see my cursor the dots
in the middle of that square those 12
dots in the middle they had other lake
records scattered to the west over in
the front or into the east in the front
range of colorado and then one up in um
the snowy range mountains up in
in wyoming and so
i don't know i don't know if you
remember 20 if you remember the fires in
2020 that was a gnarly year i was a
little bit surprised i have a lot of
friends uh in utah i thought that i
thought would be informed and they were
not aware of how crazy of a fire season
it was in colorado i was acutely aware
of it because i lived north of them and
for most of the end of the fall
it was days the smoke was so bad we
couldn't go outside where you couldn't
see the sun
so i was acutely aware of how bad these
fires were but to give you some
perspective on how bad they were in the
beginning of 20 of this summer
colorado had its largest wildfire in its
state's history um oh darn it i can't
remember what it was it burned over near
gunnison colorado up on that plateau if
you're ever driving across i-70
and you're driving through gunnison and
fruita you look to your left there's a
high mountain plateau
up over there uh the largest fire in
colorado state history burned colorado
had had lots of large fires largest one
burned in the beginning of 2020. it was
only to be the record then was broken
two more times in 2020 with these other
two fires that were in my study area
near my original study area
so it's not like 2020 needed to make it
suck anymore but 2020 decided to make it
suck a lot more
and i that's not a joke it was just kind
of like
yeah i i don't know what to say about it
i'm not going to make any covered
comments but yeah it was gnarly um
but that gave them
the impotence so these large wildfires
in that area made them think about how
we can put this these huge wildfires in
a better context we can put them in a
context with what we're seeing today and
so we can think about what i'll show you
next
is a way to evaluate these wildfires is
you can think about this question of at
current rates of burning how many years
can we expect between fires so you can
think of any spot of ground and say you
know in the last decade
we've been burning x amount of area so
how long would we would it take
for a given spot of ground to burn twice
or the time between fires
and that's the same type of calculation
as that percent of site burn in a given
century that i showed you before for my
past record so you can think of if 50 of
my sites burned in a given century well
then it would take 200 years we would
expect 200 years between fires and so we
can take these the rates of burning for
the past um century
and compare those to the rates of
burning uh from my charcoal records and
the charcoal records from from these
others they have
and so that's what this record is here
on the bottom
is that same curve that i showed you
before
with the time axis flipped i apologize
for that
to orient your eyeballs so it's going
from this is in year's
common era or years at so 2000 is you
know the year 2000 super sorry about
flipping these axes i didn't make this
figure this is my colleague who
published this paper this year
so sorry i didn't keep the time axes the
same but now you can reorient yourself
back to zero um
and then through 2080 or 2000 ce um and
this peak here at 800 years or so ce is
that same peak of fire that i showed you
before
where 83 of my site's burned but this
curve looks a little bit different
because it includes all those other lake
sites so it includes an additional eight
other lake sites in the region
to then make the same calculation
it doesn't have the percent access that
i showed you before but what it has on
the right is this years between
fires so is that
that scale that i was talking about for
how long are we going to expect between
fires given current rates of burning or
how long are we going to expect for time
between fires given past rates of
burning and so if we look at this on
average
it was about 230 years between fires and
this is something we see across the
entire western us if you go into any
forest and use your method of choice
whether you use tree rings or charcoal
or historical records and you say how
long does it how long do we have between
fires in this area it'll be somewhere
between two and four hundred years which
is what we see for our entire record
and so if we take um this metric
and then say well given the rates of
burning between 1984 and 19 and 2020
what's the amount of time that we'll
expect between fires and the rates of
burning between 1984 and 2020 which
is was a lot of fire was a lot of
burning is still within the historic
range of variability where we would
expect that those rates are burning um
to be about 230 years between fires but
as we shorten that window we
increase the weight the fire's burning
and we can see how much the rate of fire
has been changing in the decades since
then so that if we look at just the
window between 2000 and 2020
the amount of fire in those two decades
the rate of burning is such that we
would expect 117 years between fires
and if we just look at the last decade
we would expect 67 years between fires
this is a rate of burning that's not
sustainable forests cannot recover at
that rate of burning so
while that's
you wouldn't
we would never get to this point where
there are 67 years between fires because
we won't have forest at that point the
fire return interval will be such that
the forest cannot recover
and that that's a little bit
um
sobering and unfortunately while this
fire research is exciting it's always
sobering too and and the results are so
great from this study that when we look
at the last two decades of wildfire it
exceeds any it
far exceeds any range of past
variability and so um
it helps put into context you know like
we are having bad fire years we're we're
gonna live through smoke unfortunately
for the rest of the summer and that
sucks
how different is this
when we look back for thousands of years
across the wide range of the of the
western us
it's really improbable that this is
coming arising from natural consequences
we know that climate change is having an
effect
and that when we increase temperatures
by just a small amount in the past we
see a large increase in the amount of
burning and it's the same pattern we're
seeing today we can we compound that
with human effects from um
changing the forest with fire
suppression a little bit in these
forests as well as changing the forest
with beetle kills and so forth
so not to bum you out
fire research is super exciting
the results are sobering there's always
cool things to learn even if the cool
things suck
and that's the way i feel about this
fire research this is awesome this is
crazy but it also sucks so
i i love science i love data science
they give us powerful tools to answer
important questions um to help us
understand what's going on around us
and with that i'll just say thank you to
everybody that's helped me top left is
my phd advisor
super happy wonderful person if you want
to go do a phd do it with him my wife in
the middle helped me core
she
helped me lug gear into the mountains
suffered through all that with me um
as well as our little boy and some
friends that helped us along the way so
i will i will stop talking now that was
a lot
thank you very much
it was great
i'm going to open it up for questions
but first i have a question
so can you tell us more about the
analysis and one thing about pi data
that most people don't realize it even
though it has the name pi in it and that
generally references python we're
actually all about open source tools so
we support our support julia we support
python and i know john you use r to do a
lot of your uh statistical analysis can
you talk more about that process were
you using any particular uh
any particular packages that help you do
some of these uh trickier what i think
are trickier techniques
yeah i still don't know what i did i did
some stuff with no just kidding um yeah
i i use mostly r and you're right like
open source is super important the the
methods for determining the peaks of
charcoal with the mixture model that was
actually written in matlab but the
researcher and he's the one that was in
the that made the figures that i showed
you at the very end phillip era um
he was wise enough to know that we don't
all have licenses to matlab those are
expensive and he created a compiled
program that we could run
oh just natively on your operating
system i forget what it was just like it
looked like dos i don't know what it was
running off of he created a compiled
program so that we could have an open
source version um that we could use
you know across multiple operating
systems um but yeah all my work was in r
uh it was heavily dependent on all the
work
i mean it you can't do anything without
all the work that's gone before me
without all the
bayesian based modeling that's happened
before me the mcmc sampling the samplers
that have been written in c um
those are gnarly i'm not going to write
a sampler and see somebody else bless
their heart has done that for me so that
i could run uh that in r and have an
ncmc chain run really fast so that i can
do i can model sediment accumulation um
you know those were computationally
pretty intensive but i could run them on
my desktop
in a couple hours per lake so that was
some pretty reason that i could do
on a
on a
pretty weak machine
you know nothing crazy in the hardware
often
oh just all the figures the
visualizations right like i was making
figures and those like plotting programs
for investors those suck no if you want
power if you want to be able to control
everything in your figure command line
um base r
nobody's going to like base r but when i
want to make a gnarly figure i use base
r
cool
so this is my second question is
this two-part question
have you been able to translate some of
these
techniques that you use in your research
into your
daily to your daily work and
um
and to add on to that question
uh
what type of cool things could if
what could i use a mixture model for
normally in the
you know we're all about business and
making dollars right for our companies
and so
what are some of the things that you're
doing that are that require a mixture
model that would you know that would
help me maybe i can go back to the
back to my office and and throw up some
mixture models here yeah i'm smiling
really big because the first problem
they gave me so what i'm working on
right now is at mx is trying to identify
um users that own businesses where we
don't know that they own a business that
buy their transaction history we have
some high probability that they're that
they actually own a business and my
first thought was oh this is a mixture
model problem we've got
multiple populations of data we don't
know what the populations we don't know
the labels for the data um and we can
segment these into different groups
right like um one way that we can do
customer segmentation you know you think
of probably if you think customer
segmentation or any type of grouping you
think naturally you think k means um
if you want to do something
probabilistic that um assumes
some probability distribution gaussian
mixture modeling super powerful flare
are really good tools for multi and if
you have multiple dimensions right like
don't just have one dimension of
gaussian
distributions you have multiple
dimensions you can use um right now i'm
running
it on 20 something dimensions uh a
multivariate gaussian distribution so
i'm fitting
multiple multiple variation
distributions with a package called
mquest mcl
ust
um
i think these people are actually
involved in marketing too they're
researchers
that are to do like
market based research marketing based
research and they needed a really
powerful tool to do
probabilistic customer segmentation and
so they wrote this package and it's
super fast same thing i can analyze um
i mean i'm only limited in ram at that
point on my laptop we have we have
better hardware at mx than just laptops
but i'm fighting for my own and uh but
yeah i can run 100 you know i can run um
gigabytes of data on my laptop and it
can run overnight to estimate um you
know dozens of multivariate probability
distributions that you can then
calculate the probability the given
person you know is comes from a process
similar to some other users
so the next question john when are we
going to lunch because yeah
customer segmentation problem at the
moment
it's a hard problem you know and now i'm
looking at it you know it's like i'm a
hammer the whole world is nails and
i kept thinking this is a mixture model
problem and now i'm thinking no it's not
a mixture model problem it's a
mislabeled um categorization problem
i didn't know that that was a thing
until i got into industry
this everybody will nod their head what
do you do when you have mislabeled data
you have a data set that's like 80
percent correctly labeled um
yeah anyway but yeah
sorry we can go we will go out to lunch
and talk about customer segmentation
multivariate galaxy distributions and
m-class because it's super powerful and
what i like about is the probabilistic
estimates you have a probability that
somebody is similar to another person as
opposed to just like
their euclidean distance is close
whatever that means
i'm back on genes
any any other questions i've kind of
hauled his
attention
i have a quick question um so i was just
wondering
i had to duck out of this talk um for a
couple minutes did you guys record this
yes
and is the link available like um on the
on the little
meetup thing
i'll put the link in the discussion um
or i can just send it out to the entire
meetup group so okay i really appreciate
that thank you
any other questions um
definitely it was it
all right um
no worries
no i guess that's explained everything
nobody i did i explained it so poorly
that nobody has any question they can't
ask the question because they don't know
what the hell i was talking about
just kidding put our hands up alex
hey uh sorry i wanted to ask a question
real quick um
so uh where does where do you kind of
expect your research to go um for your
next set uh you're gonna be staying in
the same area or
um just keep tell a bit about little
advertisement about some of the work
that you do
um
you know for your you're given
daily tasks and everything else i sold
out i'm i'm in fintech
i i applied for a couple academic jobs
and not that i didn't want to go into
fintech but i came in second for a job
in austria felt like that was too much
of a bummer and didn't get anywhere with
any of the other jobs so i've sold out
i'm in fintech so now i'm
working with a consumer transact data
and
trying to fit these tools into into the
questions that we have there
so unfortunately
people are carrying on my research
right like the last part i showed that
was my colleagues carrying carrying on
the methods that we developed
yeah um i i guess a follow-up question
to that is um
from a like it's a broader perspective
of tools that you learned
data visualization segmentation
uh some invasion modeling you talked
about
at a broad stroke level um
how do you see that connection when you
uh in this case left academia and when
defendtech
yeah i i struggle with you know like
as an academic
we're all making these tools and so it's
natural to want to share them right like
i
created this method for analyzing these
data and so i was really careful because
i
wanted to advance our understanding it's
really careful to
document the res
document the way i did it in the methods
and make the code and data freely
available
and hopefully annotate the code enough
that somebody could follow it and and
that seemed like
that that just seemed painfully obvious
as a researcher because we want to
advance our understanding and it's weird
now in industry using these free tools
um
because somebody's going to a lot of
work and maybe not necessarily getting
paid and i don't know how long we can
sustain something like that i'm glad to
hear about um the
the group that's funding the different
open source package libraries that we
have in python um i forget the name of
it you mentioned in the beginning
lawrence um
num focus
yeah but and so you know like if i
create a really cool tool at mx um
that's really powerful that helps us
understand our data
it's kind of hard for me to just you
know
they they luckily have an emphasis in
open source software too so i think i'll
be able to argue to them like this is a
tool that we should share because it'll
help everybody everywhere um
but it's a weird one that i haven't
wrapped my head around just getting into
business how this actually works out
you know we use facebook's tools we use
profit and
um
fast text at mx
for text classification and for
financial um forecasting they created
some powerful tools tools that are
wicked fast i'm sure they have better
ones that they're not giving us but
they've made awesome tools that are open
source and available and it's it's
impressive and i yeah i i don't know how
we keep this going when we have
competing interests but
pi data sounds like a key that i should
get involved in that would help me
understand how we can keep open source
going
yeah
so um say
if you guys have questions about you
know career journey so this is one thing
that john and i both share is that we
were hardcore academics
and then we kind of got to the part of
applying for professorships and like the
reality of it is you know i'm going to
be
out in tasmania australia teaching if i
want to get a job uh kind of and just
being real and so we made a decision
saying that we're going to make this
leap and actually do this and so our
path is a little bit different you know
uh than than most so if you just have
questions centered around how did you
get to where you're at what did you
struggle with what did you were you not
expecting those types of questions are
also appropriate i want this to be open
to just more than just he's here he has
a unique experience
of coming into
from ecology of all things to come in to
do
at fintech right
i'm in the same i'm in the same boat you
know i came from doing physiology now
i'm doing like fintech right
so
they took a gamble on us
i actually have one of those questions
if you don't mind i'll share i'll show
you share my video um so
i have um
like i'm thinking about maybe going to
grad school eventually um something that
i'm just really interested in i don't
know how realistic it is but you know i
would love to get into a grad program
that does stuff either in like
computational biology or like ecology
but like um i do have a math background
i don't really have like a science
degree i have a degree in math and i am
a programmer in python
um
and so i was just wondering like
you know what are some of the best ways
that um of finding like grad programs
or um
in basically like
uh and doing research in like ecology
type stuff but obviously with lots of
computation i don't know that's kind of
my question
i mean i'm sure i have some ideas but
computational biology is the solid it
was working before i left i purposely
switched to i didn't tell what i did my
postdoc was in a computational biology
lab working with microbial dna and i
switched to do that because i thought
like how am i going to build up my chops
i did some cool stuff but i needed more
i just we always feel like we need to
know more and so i worked with a
microbial
or a micro biologist a geneticist
so that i could learn more tools with
you like how do i how do i work with a
super computer how do we work um yeah
just get more hardcore computational so
computational biology is awesome if you
think like you want to learn search
algorithms oh yeah they can do that
because that's like their whole problem
finding some repeating series
of dna sequences across terabytes of
data
yeah they've figured lots of crazy stuff
i don't know grad school is fun i worry
though i don't know what you think
lawrence i feel like um
i wonder if i would be able to make the
transition as easy in five or ten years
from academics to industry as i am right
now
there's a lack of data scientists that i
think made it easier for me for them to
gamble on me
and allow me to just make that
transition to industry which i don't
know if that'll be that way in five
years or ten years where people are
getting you know masters and data
science
specifically
uh it's interesting so i did my post-doc
computational biology also at the
national institute of health so all that
sequencing data all that that was i was
i was there doing that um
i
i never thought about the way you put it
john i think
we got in at a time in which um
our having a phd and having some
exposure to computation
uh gave us uh and we're pretty much
self-taught right
um to get there versus like i i teach at
georgetown uh university and we have
programs specifically to train uh data
scientists and to train data analysts
and
uh
it's kind of hard
to um
to actually make that sale to someone in
five you know five or ten years that
there i have all these programs and
certificates that unless you go out and
get a certificate that you're
without any proper training or
experience that you you know suitable
for these jobs but
i i stand to say a phd does
teach you the one thing that i think is
the most important skill is learning how
to learn
so um and that's what i think every data
scientist or anyone in this career has
to know how to do
uh and learn fairly quickly very complex
topics um
so
i don't i get into your grad school that
you want to go to my if i want to figure
out if i was going to computational
biology i would the first thing i would
do is go look at some of the most cited
papers that are in computational biology
or the papers that are going to be cited
are mostly going to be from the nih
um
because they have
for the longest time they have all the
money to build all the cool tools that
they get all the big publications and
they become the most cited and so
they're doing very leading work because
they have money to do it
right so things like computational
biology but the other things um there's
a
you you have to
really find some
someone that's doing something that
you're interested in
uh i
had a weird journey
i started doing research on the metal
copper and copper physiology as an
undergrad
and i met someone that came and gave a
talk and i was so interested in what she
did that whenever i applied to grad
school to harvard to all these other big
schools this professor went to oregon
right and i had to make the decision do
i go to oregon to follow this lady that
i love or do i go off to harvard or
berkeley right and i went to oregon i i
went to do that
turns out well the professor did amazing
and she took a job at hopkins so
i reapplied to grad school and went to
hopkins right it worked out for me in
the end so i tell people just follow
what you know find something that you're
really into right it'll all work out in
the end because you need and especially
the phd to really love what you're doing
so
that's my long answer
uh james
thank you very much i appreciate it
you should do it though grad school is
super fun i loved it it was the best
time of my life
minus my wedding and birth of my child
those are the best
all right well
uh thanks everyone i think that's it i
will send out a link as soon as this
video starts finish processing
um i will send out the link to everyone
thanks for coming we have a talk next
month i will send out a link for
everyone
to come to that also we have an
in-person talk at
[Music]